I think it's really important to be
around like-minded people a quote from
Louis Simmons is if you walk with the
lame you'll develop a limp when you
share a success they immediately want to
bring up their own successes to try to
measure up and if that doesn't work they
will immediately go to some negative
context around how you did it if you're
getting more out of life than I am I'm
going to sabotage you
[ __ ] pal welcome to the show thank you
so much I appreciate it for the people
that aren't familiar with you and your
background what is it
uh many many years of powerlifting
lifting some heavy ass weight and power
lifting consists of a squat a bench
press and a deadlift and so most of my
time was spent trying to build strength
in those exercises and then
in the gym when you work on a squat
bench and a deadlift
all the workouts that I did for about 30
years were all
everything was focused and honed in on
how to make those lifts stronger and you
trained under some of the
uh savants in terms of coaches of our
era yeah I got to rub elbows with Louis
Simmons Charles poliquin uh Dave Tate a
bunch of different uh kind of giants in
Fitness Giants and strength and uh Louis
Simmons I actually went and trained at
his gym West Side barbell and he was a
mentor of mine and that gym was very
very intense West Side barbell had
probably about 50 or 60 lifters in there
uh each guy probably most of the guys
were big most guys were really big like
275 and up
and uh it was intimidating there there
was a the squat rack was all the way and
it was not all the way but it was in the
back of the gym
and uh first couple times that people
went into the gym they would kind of go
by the dumbbell area they might make
their way to the bench press but most of
the time people didn't make it to the
back of the gym until they felt uh a
little more comfortable which was pretty
much never because it was uh high
intensity just everyone in there their
goal was to get as strong as possible
and not even just that some of the guys
were in there trying to be the strongest
in the world
dude I mean the legends of those stories
the videos that people have seen of west
side of Louis training yeah
[Laughter]
so what do you think um what do you
think's been lost with Louis or his
because he's now passed yeah
has his legacy managed to live on do you
think has he made a sufficient impact
that people are now taking the good
stuff that he brought in and continuing
that
I think uh some of the movements and
some of the things that he brought to
the table they're still around and
there's still a lot of people utilizing
his some of his inventions he created
the reverse hyper extension machine uh
he is the guy that brought bands and
chains and stuff like that to the
Forefront uh Dynamic effort work you
know moving weights fast he brought a
lot of attention to that so I think that
a lot of his stuff uh still lives on but
what I what I really enjoyed about
somebody like Louie Simmons is uh
his ability to be creative his ability
to also pull information from old text
uh pull information that's been around
forever and try to repurpose it and put
it back into the universe basically so
uh the things I've learned from him are
you know they're going to continue on
forever within me and they're going to
continue on uh with a lot of other
people that he mentored as well we went
for dinner last night before my
housemate Zach had his took trout which
he only got back at midnight
one of the conversations we had there
that I thought was super interesting was
about being embarrassed about your
Competitive Edge so Zach was telling
this story about how when he was younger
and in high school some of his friends
would take the piss out of him because
he would want to win he would want to do
well he would want to take things
seriously and uh I think that's such an
interesting I I see that myself it's a
very interesting
concept or topic because it's kind of
cool some people see it as cool to be
blase and nonchalant about whatever it
is that they're doing because it gives
you a get out of jail free card someone
trying hard in certain respects is a bit
kind of a bit lame but that
disincentivizes people from trying hard
and from pursuing Excellence so thinking
about West Side thinking about your
lifting history
what you're aiming to do there what it
seems like you're aiming to do is
surround yourself with people that are
chasing Excellence surrounding yourself
with people who take things seriously do
you agree
I think it's really important to be
around like-minded people uh a quote
from Louis Simmons is if you walk with
the lame you'll develop a limp and so
you want to try to get around
like-minded people and you want to kind
of question who you quote unquote run
with I had opportunity yesterday to run
with Zach bitter and we ran six miles
which to a to a runner six miles is not
really a thing but me coming from a
former powerlifting background I have
there's a lot of uh things in my head
that I have to I have to get rid of
these limiting belief factors that are
there because I could easily say well
I'm not a runner but but I am I'm
running so like what what else would
quantify me as a runner other than me
running I have competed in running
before so therefore I'm I'm a runner
just the same as him but Zach bitter is
a world record holder he he broke
all-time world record uh he ran I think
like a 634 minute mile for one 100 miles
straight which is just uh absolutely
mind-boggling to me but it's also really
inspirational to me because I'm like
I that I might have trouble doing that
because I'm not Zach
and he dedicated his whole life to it so
I'm I'm okay with saying like
it's possible that that may never happen
however
I have so much progress that I can make
because when you talk to somebody like a
Zach bitter you talk to somebody that's
broken World Records you'll ask them
you'll say hey do you think you could
have done even better and they will
start to give you a list of things that
they could have done a lot better with
so if somebody who's already really
proficient at something can get better
somebody who's uh you know reading you
know eight books a month or something
like that could they uh maybe not
necessarily read more books but could
they get more out of those books if they
are to listen to information from Tim
Ferriss years ago talking about
efficiency and how to have better
reading comprehension and things like
that so everyone that you would ask can
you get better doesn't matter if it's
the rock or whoever we put up on a
pedestal everyone has the ability to
get better at least in their own eyes I
think but that pursuit of Excellence
comes back to what we were saying before
right it's
I've only just recently realized it in
the conversation with Z over dinner last
night I can just interrupt for a second
I think
what we're alluding to is sometimes it's
hard to celebrate victories around
certain people so uh let's say I did a
million dollars in sales last month
you know it's a short list of people
that I feel I could share that with
where it doesn't feel like
all it's really saying is hey like I I'm
improving like I did this last year this
at this time for this particular month
and now I'm doing this it's not like hey
I'm a millionaire and you're not like
that's not really what I would be trying
to say uh but it's hard you know
messages all we have is our ability to
interpret stuff and we can see how ugly
things can get like email is probably
the worst text messaging isn't too far
behind
and if you have issues with people and
if you have you want to try to figure
out
what is the easiest way for this person
to interpret this information the way
that I am actually trying to convey it
and the easiest way would be
to maybe make a phone call and say hey I
would love to talk to you more about
this in person uh because there's a lot
of intricacies of what I'm trying to
communicate that I can't put through the
text think about all of the hurdles that
you're having to jump over just in order
to be able to celebrate a win with
someone that's supposed to be on your
side this isn't to say like lots of
people that I'm around are perfectly
happy to celebrate my wins like me and Z
tell each other each day about what it
is that we think's gone well the day
before and it's not a dick measuring
competition between each of us it's one
of the reasons that we get on so well
but the idea that Excellence is a lonely
Pursuit is one that I don't think most
people think about they have those
studies with the lobsters where the
lobsters gets depressed and uh they
won't play with the other lobsters
unless they like play nice and I think
they've done studies with mice and stuff
like that too I believe Jordan Peterson
has referenced uh some of this as well
they need to let the other mice win at
least 30 of the time other mice just
stop playing they're like I'm done so
another example of this would be you
know if I am to do some Jujitsu with my
co-host in Sema
like we can't really we could we could
like play it and he could show it to me
and I I don't have any Proficiency in
Jiu Jitsu he's a purple belt and Jiu
Jitsu he's gonna [ __ ] you up a brown
belt actually yeah he's gonna he's gonna
he's gonna destroy me and so uh
I think when we're talking about
expressions of greatness uh
it's important it's important to match
it up against who you know who who is it
matched up with and who is it matched up
against if I share uh if I share
business success with a business-minded
person who's already a Savage they're
like
that's pretty cool you know what though
you could actually did you think about
doing this I have a whole you know
company that does this uh on Instagram
and on Tick Tock have you guys done that
yet because I bet you can double and
triple and you're you know you were
thinking like this is pretty good and
they they kind of you're leaving
something on the table and you do end up
in the dick measuring contest I do get I
understand what you mean especially with
regards to BJJ that's a tight Pursuit
that's inherently competitive like a
conversation between you and a bro like
I do YouTube you do Finance or you do
art like
zaxmisses is a painter right she
releases like these fantastic paintings
and drawings on the internet and sells
them for tons of money if I tell her
about some cool guest that I just had on
that's two completely different domains
and that's basically what I'm talking
about like
the ability to have a group of people
around you who you can talk about your
successes with in a domain that they are
not competing with you in and have them
support you
still requires a good bit of hurdle
jumping unless you're around like a very
specifically sort of tuned person and
what the this story from Zach sort of
taught me was that he was
disincentivized from chasing his own
Excellence because he became embarrassed
about it he became embarrassed by his
friends
for being the kind of person that takes
things seriously that wants to improve
and that wants to win
and
I I don't know I just struggle to see
any scenario in which that would be an
advantageous life philosophy like you're
literally you're encouraging somebody to
regress to the mean like hang on you're
doing something different to us why why
would you do that I've got a chip on my
shoulder about this but like still it's
just
it's a culture that I would love to try
and completely annihilate as much as I
can if you're getting more out of life
than I am I'm gonna sabotage you yes
and I think that I think that that is uh
I feel it I feel it sometimes you know
when somebody mentions something to me
I'm like I I I I I'm thinking of me me
me way to bring that person down to uh
reduce the gap between you yeah what's
the story that I can share how do I fit
into that I win
um you know you uh mentioned that you
had this really wonderful opportunity
and I'm like
how do I I and then for me personally
um I have to work on that a bunch and I
have to think
well we're just different people like he
has a different Pursuit that's really
cool I kind of wonder how he did that
and my then I would have a question for
you rather than a statement and I think
I think more of our conversations I
think it'd be great to end him with a
question mark
rather than a period because a period is
just a statement that you just said and
you're it's like uh a little bit more
definitive but when we end it with a
question mark you're asking a question
and now we can kind of go back and forth
and I can learn more about what you did
to get there it's an interesting thing
when you I think
people when you share a success
they immediately want to bring up their
own successes to try to measure up and
if that doesn't work
they will immediately go to some
negative context
around how you did it maybe it was
through performance enhancing drugs or
maybe it was through uh your dad owns a
gym and so of course you're stronger
than lucky timing first mover advantage
there's all those things all those bells
and whistles that go off I've made many
posts about this in the past it's easier
for me because I'm rich it's easier for
me because I'm ripped it's easier but
there was a time where even Within
Myself where I felt dumb I was pretty
broke you know there was times where
fluffy fluffy very fluffy I got very
fluffy
yeah there were some fat times back then
uh
but again I think the the key factor is
can you get better and when you are
communicating with somebody that's
trying to share something with you
it's also okay just to compliment them
and then
in terms of receiving compliments
people really fail at that too that's a
really good point people stink at that I
I uh I spent years deflecting so many uh
compliments from fans and I was like
that is really foolish of me why can't I
just say thank you and give the person a
hug it's uncomfortable that's why if
someone comes up to you and says Mark I
just wanted to let you know shouldn't be
uncomfortable like we're we're we go to
Great Lengths to to try and have that
impact get these Studios and get these
lights and have these cameras and these
microphones maybe I I this is going to
be super idiosyncratic right like your
motivation for doing it might be
different to mine might be different to
somebody else's but I remember I was at
body power in 2018 So Classic fitness
expo shut off I've been doing doing the
muscle ups on a CrossFit rig and stuff
like that this guy came up and told me a
really meaningful story about his father
passed away and this thing from the show
and blah blah blah and he starts weeping
and then I start weeping I'm like oh
[ __ ] like I'm supposed to be in this
testosterone-fueled Alpha Fest and
there's me with tears rolling down my
face because this guy's just told me
this beautiful story about how he's
reconnected with his family and all of
this stuff just fantastic
and then I realized that the opportunity
although stories might not hit quite so
emotionally hard every time
the opportunity for me to connect with
uh a nice message from somebody or
something like that rather than
rather than I don't know where the
discomfort comes from I don't know where
but it is it is there even though that's
the thing that you're seeking you know
somebody watches you do a presentation
at work or a sales call at work or
whatever or you start going to the gym
and you look better or something and a
lot of the time someone will give you a
compliment what I found myself doing for
a good while was I would come up with a
excuse about why that compliment didn't
really matter so for instance if someone
came up and said oh hey man like you're
looking bigger you must have been
training pretty hard go oh well uh you
know it's easy when you don't have a
life outside of the gym like just
classic defense just completely and it
makes the person that gave the
compliment feel like [ __ ] you don't
actually imbibe what it is that they're
saying because you've created an excuse
about why that compliment doesn't really
matter and it it is such a good point to
say that taking compliments is a skill
because
you're disincentivizing other people
from telling you something that would
make you feel better and maybe that's a
thing like me saying oh you know I wish
that there was more support and I hate
told poppy syndrome in British culture
and blah blah blah I wasn't massively
receptive to the antithesis of tall
poppy syndrome I wasn't being super
receptive to that so maybe it was my
fault in fact it almost certainly would
have been contributed to by me
I think again I think uh quite you know
questioning stuff and just have it
getting into good conversation with
somebody somebody is really
complimentary uh hey I love those bench
videos you did years ago I got me into
powerlifting uh powerlifting got me out
of you hear people always say like dark
times got me out of Hard Times Dark
Times
I will usually follow that up with like
hey if you don't mind me asking like
what were those dark times so it's
can you
just for a second stop being such an
[ __ ] and can you communicate with
somebody and ask them about themselves I
think we have a hard time doing that
even in relationships
um you know like with my wife and I
we've been married for 20 plus years
uh we we do the best we can with that we
try to say like like how you know how
are you doing you know how was your how
was your day
and then you know my wife my wife might
fill it in with uh oh you know Quinn did
this that's our daughter and Jake Jake
did that and I had to take them
baby
how was your day like how like you know
and she was like oh it was really cool I
got an opportunity to swam in the
morning and I got to read a book
afterwards and I talked to my mom you
know I imagine as a mother
that that uh placing personal worth a
second to the family to the like I
imagine that that must just be [ __ ]
endemic amongst women yeah I think 100
percent
100 I just again when somebody is is
complimenting you and you start to uh
you start to get into these
conversations and and even amongst
friends that this is what good friends
should be doing with each other we
should be complementary of each other we
should be asking more questions
somebody's sharing with you
that they read something really
interesting what you'll find yourself
doing you'll say actually in 2019 there
was a study that uh diffused that whole
thing that you just said about
cholesterol or whatever it might be and
it's like
I think a better stance would be to ask
another question ask a follow-up
question say hmm that is actually quite
different than something I learned years
ago what's your belief on this and learn
like continue to learn more you already
have that stored in your head and maybe
you can bring this this other conjecture
up as you move forward but I don't think
it's a great way to like you know hit
somebody with right off the bat assuming
that the person that you're speaking to
has something worthwhile that you could
learn from them is just such a fantastic
first principle but yeah
I wonder about
the challenges that people have of
holding themselves to high standards as
well so this is there's kind of a
double-edged sword right that in order
to be excellent at a thing you need to
demand a lot of yourself but as soon as
you posit an ideal you then begin to put
yourself in whatever you do in reference
to that ideal which inevitably creates a
gap like if this is what you want
anything that you do is always going to
be in reference to that and even if you
overshoot your ability as a type A
driven person to go actually I meant
this go catch back I meant this and you
just continue to one of my friends
refers to it as like running toward the
Horizon that every time you take a step
toward it it takes a step away from you
and um
that
learning to be able to be more holistic
with your pursuit of goals and high
standards specifically I think is
something
that takes a very long time to work out
how to do in a way that isn't toxic I
got a question for you do you think
do you think that people uh
uh like might not be aware that they're
negative and and in addition to that do
you think there's some people that um
maybe you're unaware or maybe they feel
as if they're like making progress and
they're really they're really maybe not
moving forward like people that are
negative and just like stuck I would say
so there's certainly people I'm not sure
about the progress thing the progress
thing might be more difficult to hide
from
um but the negativity 100 that you can
be in a environment that treats
negativity it Praises negativity so
maybe their interpretation of even what
they perceive as being negative yes uh
maybe they don't even believe that it's
that negative maybe they just think it's
their nature correct and or maybe that's
just the way that you're supposed to
respond you know I mean this is the
British art form of piss taking and
satire right like that's what where
that's one of the things that we're
really really good at and it's fantastic
in a comedy but it's not great for
personal development and it's one of the
things that I love about America that
you guys genuinely support success like
someone does well and I'm sure that
there's subcultures in America that's
full of people that are like tall poppy
tear downers as well but
if you find the right group of people
out here I think the American dream
super really is still alive you do well
and people want to raise it up and they
go wow man like that's that's awesome
and the sense finishes that it's like
that's not it's not that's awesome but
that's awesome and it's like that's
awesome congratulations for you
um but yeah another thing that you were
talking about with
why we sometimes struggle to accept
compliments for what they are we were
talking about this over dinner last
night again as well the asymmetry in
what we experience of our own lives and
what we see of everybody else is because
our own inner experience is so rich this
textured world and we understand the
decision that we make we see every
single different vacillation backward
and forward it could be this it could be
that it could be the whatever and all
that the world ever sees is what you end
up doing at the end of that I'm gonna
have the chicken sandwich or the beef
sandwich chicken beef chicken uh beef
right and then you end up doing it and
that's for everything for the business
decisions that you make for the partner
you choose for the life all of that
stuff and I think inevitably it leads us
to have for the most part a lot of
self-doubt because everybody else just
looks like this really smooth acting
self-reliant agent that seems to be able
to make [ __ ] happen and we see us tumble
over our own decisions from a friend
receipt on a daily basis and I think
that that asymmetry
[Music]
um
can lead us to
not value simple compliments and simple
successes perhaps as much as we should
because we see all of the stumbles that
we took on route to getting there
a hack for me over the years uh and this
probably had to do with uh perhaps some
Financial Freedom and getting into
positions where
uh maybe I felt strong enough and
confident enough to
the maybe hand opportunities to people
but I've found so much utility in
sometimes I'm probably to some people
I'm probably almost annoyingly kind like
I I want to assist people like there's
people in my life
there's people that are in my phone and
things like that that I know I have the
ability to assist and to help
and so I'll send them a lot of messages
text messages voice messages
but it's been really it's been a really
amazing thing for me to think how can I
connect this person with somebody else
how do I this person's amazing like I
can't even I can't even believe how
awesome uh Andrew huberman is who came
to my gym a while back and was on my
podcast and stuff like that how do I
share him with more people how do I
figure that out I you know I could share
them on my Instagram like that's a good
start but what about maybe connecting
with uh some potential
um uh sponsors and stuff like that for
his show and the reason why I think that
way is because that'll just help me look
better too so selfishly there's there's
always a little selfishness and wrapped
up in everything I think and so
selfishly uh that's wrapped in there as
well but I I would love for him
and people like him to feel better to
feel more comfortable and they think
about me or they think about my team or
they think about super training or they
think about anything to do with me my
products the podcast I want them to have
a really good feeling about it you know
that friend that when you see him like
you just start laughing like you're
you're a hundred feet away you see them
at the airport they come pick you up or
something like that or or you saw them
in an unexpected he went to the coffee
shop that day and and there's your old
buddy who is always hilarious he's he's
no drama and you're he just light up
automatically just start laughing you
start thinking
I don't necessarily have that
personality that way to be that quite
that Dynamic maybe but
I think my strengths a lot of time is in
is in connecting people so for people
listening that feel like they can
connect the dots here and there for
somebody which I think everybody can if
you really think about it because
we know a lot of people and we're in
closer proximity to people than than
ever before just with social media so if
uh this is an example of this would be
if you heard something uh that you felt
could serve somebody else and it's just
a message on a podcast or Instagram
copy it paste it shoot it over to a
friend maybe it helps change your life I
think
it's a interesting Nuance to consider
the respective glow the reflective glow
that you end up basking in when you do
the thing like for Andrew you know he's
phenomenal and should have more people
than the like mountains that already
listen to him listening to him because I
think science-based tools for health and
fitness and wellness and mindfulness and
stuff is great but there is a you can
start to feel a little selfish or a
little guilty because you know that
there's something coming back to you but
ultimately any selfless act has a a
selfish component even if it's
completely subconscious because by doing
something selfless you're ultimately
going to get a good a sense of Good Will
from it studies that have been done
which I'm sure you're familiar with
where they give people 10 pounds and
they say you can spend this on yourself
or you can spend this on something for
someone else and the difference in the
amount of pleasure that people take from
the money they spend on somebody else is
way more to go okay so the most selfish
thing I can do is to be selfless okay
how do I do something selfless then
genuinely how do you do something that
is at its purest sense selfless well I
would need to do something that's for
someone else but somehow didn't make me
feel better but where's the incentive to
do that and if you can have a positive
sum game they feel better I feel better
fantastic they feel better I feel worse
maybe but that's somehow what more
[ __ ] virtuous I don't understand but
yeah I think the connecting thing I've
been a club promoter for 15 years man
it's like in My DNA now whatever
epigenetic for uh networking has been
switched on and it just doesn't stop and
um
the connecting thing Connecting People
thing is so cool and there is a little
bit of a a winner takes all power law
Matthew principle thing going on because
the more contacts you have the more
people you can connect and the more
people that you connect the more
contacts you get which means that
there's more opportunities we were out
there going like how do you know someone
from this place oh yeah I know someone
from that place like do you know someone
from here oh yeah you should really
intro the blah blah blah
um so you do start to see
coalitions of people move and win
together but going back to the very
beginning about supporting each other's
excellences being in a community of
people that wants to raise others up as
opposed to tear them down or even just
be neutral about what it is they're
doing if you support that person
you can fly along with them like when I
think about some of the people that I've
been around and some of the different
positions they've got themselves into
the same names keep popping up like
there is no reason that you should
continue to be an absolute beast in this
industry and that industry and oh you
also happen to be an amazing Trader and
also you know you know tons about crypto
and you know about investment you've got
some stuff to do with content creation
well why and also why would I want that
person to be around me so yeah I think
the networking thing is interesting
because it's become very transactional
people can see it as like what can I do
for them if they can do something for me
but ultimately if you do that from a
virtuous holistic I want everyone to be
better place
I think that you can do that without
feeling too guilty
yeah and that's the way I view it I view
it as
over time you're gonna understand who I
am better
so I'm not I'm not concerned about I'm
not concerned about uh if the person in
the back of their heads like oh is this
guy trying to do something because you
know hopefully I know you more than just
for like a month and hopefully I know
you more than just a transaction of you
coming in and doing my podcast that's
why I invite so many people out to my
gym in Sacramento my headquarters where
I have my podcasts and everything's
Under One Roof is because they get to
see my employees they get to see the
vibe there they get to see everything
just like we're doing here at Nick's
place we're at bpn headquarters and this
is absolutely uh amazing facilities got
the gym and everyone here is super kind
and each person has their own journey
and their own story guy was telling us
about losing over 100 pounds so there's
like you know these remarkable stories
everywhere and I think these guys get it
like they
they know and understand and probably a
lot of that's been uh handed down from
Nick of uh just figuring out ways of
being helpful
there was this story that I remembered
from Peterson live talk that I went to
go and see Manchester this must have
been
2017 or 2018. this is before the guy
even knew who I was and uh
he was in Manchester Northern Town in
the UK a lot of Gangland sort of
violence and stuff outside of that and
there's boxing gyms and one of these
particular boxing gyms that's placed in
the middle of a gang area that's the
safe haven for these young kids so that
they don't get picked up by The Gangs
right and it's a classic story of some
you know patriarch leader tough grizzled
Northern British man who's been a boxing
coach for 40 years or whatever and he's
telling the kids what for and he's got
the flat cap on and stuff like that and
Jordan went to go and see these kids and
he was talking about it during the Q a
and uh one of these stories this young
guy said that uh he had been trying to
spend more time reading and learning at
home and it was his mum and his stepdad
and his stepdad it seemed like it was
treating him pretty badly or whatever
and uh his stepdad came in one evening
and like hit this book out of his hands
and said what are you reading for like
this readings readings for idiots or
like do you think that you it's not
going to make any difference in any case
and Peterson in his sort of classic
where he gets this gnarled finger out
and he goes if you want to punish
somebody tell them that they're wrong
for doing something wrong but if you
really want to punish somebody tell them
they're wrong when they do something
right and [ __ ] man like I was I'm sat
there like with hairs standing up on the
back of my neck so I go that's that
disincentivizing Excellence then thing
all over again and just trying to get
people out of the scarcity mindset and
into the abundance mindset that's one of
the biggest changes I think that you can
make because every single interaction
that you see is an opportunity every
single time that you sit down with
somebody that you meet somebody this is
an opportunity for me to learn from them
for me to connect with them for me to
make their day better and it's you don't
need to get into woo and spiritual Karma
although we are in the like capital of
that at the moment in Austin
you don't need that you can just say
look I I just feel like this would be a
better way to exist from first
principles I think it's a better way to
exist I think when your brain is is
honed in on like better I think it's it
starts to hone in on better for
everything maybe I could have better
language maybe I can be better educated
maybe I can make uh better decisions
better choices with my food
that's how it's worked out for me and I
feel like uh it's an incredible feeling
it's hard to communicate because I would
love to basically just make a post on
social media and be like I feel [ __ ]
awesome I feel amazing and a lot of it's
because of ABC
um that'll be received pretty good by
some people but it also I can't control
how it's perceived by by everybody but
it is literally how I feel in this
pursuit of trying to make things better
and I think it all starts for me it
started with just putting more time in
other people like just not being in a
rush
when I communicate with somebody
I don't have somewhere to be I'm [ __ ]
with you and I love I love spending time
with people there are times where yes I
do need the [ __ ] Jet and I need to go
uh but
when I'm driving home in my car and I'm
like
yeah I'm like damn like I shouldn't have
probably spent that 30 minutes with that
person because
it doesn't really impact much but then
I'm like no no it impacted them so you
got to remember that like that's
you know and I and I gotta I gotta stick
by that that was okay that was the right
decision and I gotta communicate that to
myself throughout the day and it's been
something that just it just makes me
feel good I just feel at peace so
sometimes when I hear of somebody uh
making a lot of money or somebody just
making these big moves
um I don't I'm not in a spot in my life
where I feel like I need to come at that
with anything negative I'm not in a spot
in my life where I feel like I need to
match that it's something that I'm
probably not completely over uh maybe I
never will maybe there's some
competitive nature in there or something
like that
um but to go back to what we were saying
in the beginning about uh you know not
wanting to maybe shine too much or not
wanting to just Crush everybody with
what you're good at
I I think that there's appropriate times
there's appropriate times to bring stuff
up so if somebody uh
if somebody is mentioning they're really
struggling on their diet well maybe
that's where you can start to start to
say hey I learned I learned this and I'm
really excited this helped and this
helped well they just mentioned that
they're kind of open the door for you to
lay out some groundwork for them
but if they don't and you're trying to
impose this way of living on them that's
when we get in a really dangerous
situations because I don't know how much
judging we can really do it's it's tough
when somebody's you know when somebody's
heavy we would like to automatically
think well that person's 60 pounds
overweight and we know that that makes
you unhealthy
we kind of know that but we don't
there's there's some pretty decent
evidence but also maybe you know if that
person's 60 pounds overweight for just
two three years maybe it's not that
detrimental we have no idea where the
person came from we have no idea a
glimpse into uh what their life looks
like and so trying to uh you know
enforce or trying to push an agenda on
somebody just is something that probably
is going to fall short it's interesting
the balance between being sufficiently
gentle with the messaging with the
framing with how you put it across uh we
were talking about how
some women that gain an awful lot of
weight do so in response to sexual
trauma that they've been through in
their past and that by gaining a ton of
weight they
think that they exclude themselves from
being an object of sexual desire so they
use their weight as a protection
strategy so that they never go through
that potential assault or whatever again
and you go okay and here's someone some
well-meaning person going have you heard
of carb cycling before because carb
cycling is a very uh I've got this local
this local guy is great they're like
high intensity classes but they're going
to be gentle on your joints meanwhile
you've got this sort of inner trauma
just screaming out and
that is
a very difficult line to walk you know
how do you how do you push hard enough
with someone and this is another another
interesting
um progression I think that people go
through as they grow up a lot of the
things that people are developing when
they start you know the 20 to 30s
strategies how to stop being a man child
the basics of productivity the basics of
a health and fitness regime I need to
get up and go to bed at the same time
blah blah blah that's interesting what
interests me more now is how you get
from 80 to 90 not how you get from
naught to 30. okay I know that I can
push with Z I can tell him dude I think
that video sucked like I don't like the
pacing I don't like the this I don't
like that and I know that he's ready to
take it and sufficiently robust and that
again is what's important about growing
and evolving as you progress because
it's the same as in the gym you're not
going in and squatting one plate for one
rep whereas when you first started you
did progressively over time you're going
to add more stress and more load because
the greater stress and the greater load
are going to yield greater results but
you don't do that in the beginning you
also don't don't do that with beginners
even if you're an advanced person so
yeah maybe maybe when we were talking
before about
curating the message for the audience
making sure that it is
well received but I'd heard you say once
that you you don't have bad days or
you've never never had bad days what do
you mean by that
I mean exactly what I said
uh I think you know I've been working
over the last several years maybe even
like a decade I'm just reinterpretation
uh it's my belief and I try not to get
too attached to those as well but it's
my current belief that
negative emotions they only come from
one spot
negative emotions come from negative
interpretations
and there are some things in life where
you're like I think that's [ __ ]
because sometimes
like something like rape or something
like that there are things that are like
it's just bad like it's it's a it's a
[ __ ] horrible thing to have happen to
somebody
uh so there are things that
that are that are things that are
nuanced that are like maybe outside the
budget sometimes sometimes on some of
these things but uh it's my belief that
uh negative uh interpretations uh are
the thing that spark spark a negative
emotion and it could lead you down a bad
path and so when I
started to think about some of these
things and I review them in my head I
start to clean out the closet of my
previous ideas and I start to go through
and I start to evaluate and I start to
say
oh like me when I grew up and I thought
I was dumb I thought I bought this story
that I was stupid
um
there was really nothing bad about that
I needed a unique I grew up uh upper
middle class no friction anywhere so
it's like I needed some sort of friction
to uh me personally I'm not saying
everybody needs that kind of friction
but I needed friction to fine-tune
myself and what did me thinking that I
was dumb thinking that I wasn't going to
be able to maybe do stuff other kids
could do
in school it pushed me towards being
more physical so I lifted weights and it
turned turned into a thing it turned
into something for me it pushed me so
far that way so when I think about
you know good days and bad days I could
think about those frustrating times I
had in school and now I can look at them
and be like no those were things that
really helped to mold me because you're
the things that make you uh the things
that make you cry the way I kind of view
it is uh your brain is just it's just
working through a bunch of stuff
I say Lift through it I also will share
the idea of run through it a lot of
people that I've run into that lift and
run or exercise
when they when they go and do these
things they are working out traumas is
like a strong word uh but they're
they're working through [ __ ] when they
go and lift when you talk to somebody
about their weight loss journey to find
out that someone lost 100 pounds
a lot of times there's some sort of
Trauma from their childhood when you
talk to somebody that's obese and
they're working through it with their
diet and with their exercise so the
things that really uh
may have hurt you at a particular time
I think when you heal from those things
you're a little stronger and you're a
little more resilient and over the years
you know I'd certainly didn't start out
this way but I've always had a pretty
calm demeanor and it's just gotten more
and more calm over the years to the
point where sometimes even that's
misinterpreted me just not saying
anything could be like wow he's maybe he
was in a bad mood you know well maybe it
doesn't come maybe I don't care and
really it's just a balance I have what I
believe I I'm starting to get better at
is having some Equanimity Equanimity is
just a balanced mind in the face of
adversity in the face of something that
somebody else might otherwise perceive
as a stressful situation so people get
into these uh arguments and they get in
these fights with people and they get
into these little nasty
things here and there and your emotions
will flow a particular way what I've
learned is they don't necessarily have
to because you have an opportunity to
think about your thoughts a little bit
more if you can pause
and just take a second you're going to
find that your delivery and your
reaction to whatever it was is probably
going to be more efficient more
effective a lot of times that's not
really what we're taught though because
you know if you play a sport especially
as a male play football play cricket
whatever support you may have played up
doing
that you chose a lot of reaction time is
is a big factor in there and your
response to what's happening is critical
now that's on the physical side but on
the mental side it's
it it couldn't be any more important I
can't think of any uh greater strategy
than just pausing something for a moment
say you got into an argument with your
significant other
and you said
I'm not I'm not exactly sure
um but I'm I'm really frustrated and I
need to think about that can you can we
is it possible can we can we shut this
down for a minute uh and and can I come
back and talk to you more about this in
like five minutes
I know how difficult that can be but I
can't think of a more effective strategy
sometimes people will say you know sleep
on it which that could even be more
difficult and never run through it yeah
and a lot of times that's that's where
the things will work out I think if you
do stuff physically uh it really has a
benefit but anyway just yeah just uh
over the years as I started to think
about it more I was like oh yeah I've
only had a couple bad days my mom died
you know a couple years back
my oldest brother died he was bipolar
and had uh drug problems and stuff like
that my mom basically died from obesity
and so she was a hard person to try to
get to head in the right direction and
take the the steps that we're even
talking about right here
and so that's why I feel like I can
speak upon these things because these
are things that I have had to work on
and part of the reason why I even went
down the road of studying things like
Equanimity and stoicism
is because of people like my mother
because I'm like I know that she can do
some of these things I know that she can
make some of these changes but to be
honest with you at this stage in my life
I am actually thoroughly confused on
whether people possess the ability to
truly change or not
it's a it's a really interesting thing
when you start to really uh think about
it deeper and deeper
but it's a it's a it's a tall task for
some people if they haven't started to
change some of their mindset already uh
it's like I'm not even going to bother
to climb uh that mountain because I'm
going to be embarrassed that I'm I'm
only going to get a couple hundred
meters up it unfortunately
um I
I wonder
what the future generation of young
people will look like ones that have
been exposed to self-development from a
younger age I'm sure that this is the
case for everyone but
every generation looks back at people
that are when they're 34 at kids that
are 14 and goes I remember me when I was
14. I didn't look like that act like
that think like that talk like that be
around friends like that spend my time
like that and it permanently seems like
uh kids are maturing more quickly
sometimes in ways that are worse than
others and maladaptive but
I wonder whether that sense of agency
sovereignty ability to enact change
within our lives I wonder whether that's
going to be democratized a little bit
more I wonder whether people are going
to feel that but
dude that's a really good question like
just how much
just how much leeway do people have to
change yeah in your experience I mean
you've been studying a lot of this it
seems like from my communication with
you so far it seems like not only are
you listening to stuff but I'm imagining
that you're like taking notes I mean you
took notes last night a little bit on
the conversation we had do you find
yourself like diligently like it's
almost like you're still in school no so
the reason I did it last night is
because there was stuff that was so good
I didn't want to miss it today but
I am pretty undisciplined when it comes
to note-taking or having an external
second brain a bunch of my friends Ali
abdal Thiago Forte these guys literally
wrote the book he wrote a book called
building a second brain like he's got
the thing created however for me it just
doesn't work and the best way that I've
found which might be a cope because I
don't have the system is Tim ferriss's
the good [ __ ] sticks the stuff that
resonates with you is the stuff that
you'll carry with you and if it didn't
stay in your brain it wasn't meant to be
there now you can lean on the side of
being lackadaisical with that and end up
just forgetting everything and go well
nothing's sufficiently interesting it
was that seems unlikely I feel like my
um the rate of income uh or input and
the rate of retention is pretty well
balanced now um but a big chunk of that
is because I have an outlet that I'm
always looking for stuff to use on you
know another story about Winston
Churchill's Ministry of ungentlemanly
warfare or whatever book I'm reading
like that's a story that I'm using
because I have an outlet if people don't
have that they have less incentive to
retain which means they have less
incentive to grow it's fortunate that in
between the income or the input for me
and the output of being on the show I
end up taking stuff for myself it has to
go through me and during that that
forces me to change so I wonder whether
a vehicle for change for people a men's
group A Woman's Group a friend that's
really inquisitive some sort of creative
Pursuit like a sub stack or painting or
poetry or music or whatever
I wonder whether as more people do that
and as more people get interested in not
just being consumers but in being
creators
whether that will encourage them to do
more but yeah man it it's sad to think
you know that our parents generation
didn't necessarily have that
belief put in them so early what I think
is interesting about that generation is
that
that generation kicked so much ass and
made so much money that people aren't
hurting nearly as badly as you think and
I know people are like oh he's a free to
say you're rich uh
during the pandemic and and during these
times where a lot of businesses had to
shut down and people really did they
were suffering at a point uh there's
still people with a refrigerator full of
food a freezer full of food a cupboard
full of food and there's still people uh
there's still people stacking up like
just really shitty unhealthy Foods I
mean what did people do during the
pandemic
they ordered [ __ ] doordash I mean
but then people are talking about their
stress their anxiety it's like
again it's it's hard right to not come
from a place of being judgmental but
you're like man like
you just told me that you want to
completely get rid of this drinking
problem and you just you just downed a
whole bottle of vodka like what's going
on here like
and and I that's in my view that's what
we saw we saw people were hurting uh
during that time and we saw people going
through some hard [ __ ] but I do think
that the generation of like my dad who's
probably 74 75 now
um I think that generation put up so
many [ __ ] points on the scoreboard of
life that a lot of at least in America a
lot of people are set up pretty well
my dad has been doing taxes for a really
long time and could be the area where he
does taxes or whatever but uh he's been
doing it probably maybe 40 years or
something like that maybe 50 years
I was like that I'm like these people
anybody that you do taxes for like
do they not have a fridge full of food a
freezer full of food and Pantry full of
food he's like you know they all do and
I'm like well and and uh oh he said and
even and he goes from Furthermore they
usually have a free a freezer in their
garage that has you know more food in
there so
that generation they did miss out on
some really cool stuff they missed out
on
believing in yourself and believing that
you couldn't probably uh achieve higher
things and you might be able to choose
your own path it was Millennia but they
they they took a path and they did it
and they didn't really know if there was
other options and you got to kind of
think that their parents like my grandpa
and stuff like that worked on the
Railroad and like
there was an even more direct like there
was no conversation about
you trying to go to a different College
you were going to this you were going to
this school and then you're going to
this school and then you're working the
railroad or whatever maybe they didn't
have an opportunity to go to college
right I think college was something that
was you know from 30 40 years ago well
think about the
challenges that people face when they
don't have those different opportunities
when they don't at a young age get given
all of those but then on the flip side I
think that the pendulum swings back too
far and we now have the Paradox of
choice people have so many different
life routes that they can go down
there's I I wonder if there's a name for
it I haven't found one yet but commonly
when people leave University
and for the first time since the age of
four or five they're now freewheeling on
their own they've been on train tracks
all of this time up until the age of 21
22 23 and they're released into the open
world and they go holy [ __ ] I can go
anywhere that I want even if I've been
on the the tightest track of medicine or
chartered accounting or you know
Dentistry or whatever that kind of has a
very obvious progression there's still a
sense of Free Falling because they go
well what do I do since the age of five
years old when I had to get up where I
had to be what I had to learn what I was
expected to do the progression over time
the time I was going to spend away the
time that was going to be all of that
has just been prefabricated for me
and now I'm released into the world
ostensibly as an adult
but functionally as a child
and I have to make all of these
decisions and Barry Schwartz is the
Paradox of choice suggests that it looks
fantastic when you give people a ton of
different options because it allows them
to choose an option which is closer to
the precise thing that they actually
wanted but what it ends up with
happening I [ __ ] I learned this stat
about Jam right so uh
when there were fewer types of jam
I was talking about like peanut butter
and jelly type stuff correct yeah so we
would call it Jam like a preserve yeah
over here
um
40 or 50 years ago I think there were
like six times fewer different
variations of this particular product
we're talking about but they sold
50 more and there may be a whole host of
reasons for why preserves aren't being
used as much I don't know but the
argument that was put forward is this
Paradox of choice the fact that when you
go in and you have you get paralysis by
analysis you look at all of these
different types of jam and you go we'll
draw on the marmalade with bits or
without bits do I want it to be the
orange I don't want it to be the blood
orange like all of this stuff and I
think that the same thing happens with
life that people have all of these
different options in front of them and
that that can cause them a high degree
of anxiety because they know that if
their life ends up in a place that they
didn't mean it to be it feels like it's
more on them
and there is a beauty to having a
reduction in the number of choices that
you can make you know for all that we
can say look Downstream from it at what
our parents have got to deal with with a
reduced amount of sovereignty and more
challenges and a lack of sort of
self-belief in being able to change the
direction and stuff like that yes
but they also didn't have the pain of as
many decisions or maybe even any
decisions you know go back we've got
this sort of mating crisis thing going
on at the moment with men and women not
being able to find partners that they
feel attracted to and a hundred and 200
years ago in the year of Darwin's birth
which was 1830 the average number of
divorces in the UK was four that's not
thousand that's not million four per
year right if you naturally marry the
daughter of the owner of the farm that's
next to your family's Farm
I mean and you still see this this is
still rolled forward in arranged
marriages in Indian culture right I have
a bunch of friends that are Indian that
are in arranged marriages that didn't
know their partner or basically didn't
know their partner before they ended up
getting married with them and the
familiarity has bred love off the back
of that so
it's such a an interesting conversation
to be had around like how many choices
should we give people like for the
increased choice and sovereignty there
is an Associated degree of anxiety and
where's the line that we need to draw
and for some people that's great I feel
like I like having that because I like
sort of being the master of my own fate
and I like wrestling with the challenge
of what am I supposed to do
but for somebody else that's differently
wired that might just turn them inside
out and it's turned me inside out for a
big chunk of time maybe I'll just be
better off if I was marrying the [ __ ]
farmer's daughter I don't know
it gets to be difficult because there's
uh
your choices are really important
like what you choose is is really
important but I think what you could
potentially do is if you fill your plate
up enough uh there's less room for you
to do [ __ ] stuff so what we did last
night with the protein that protein
leveraging that we did we just had
protein dish after protein dish and
we're stacking up over 100 grams of
protein each
it doesn't really allow for much all the
way to the point when the dessert menu
came it didn't even really look
appetizing because like we got after it
with the steak and the shrimp and the
steak Tartar and the tuna tartar and it
was just like endless amounts of food
there
I think that people should stuff
themselves and fill themselves up with
like I do this
so much sometimes that it's it's it's to
a point where I almost feel nauseous and
I'm not talking about with food but in
terms of the education process
uh on the way here I was listening to a
podcast
um I'm always trying to not always but
I'm often times because sometimes I just
like downtime but I oftentimes am
uh thinking of ways of like how can I
learn something right now or how could I
be do so doing something uh maybe just
how can I enhance this it's part of the
reason why our podcast the podcast that
I run we have a stand-up desk because
I'm like well you just burn more
calories when you're standing up but I
don't want to sit for three hours every
day and you know maybe that's going to
bug my hip and cause me to be stiff and
stuff and so uh while we're doing the
podcast I got lacrosse ball I'm like
rolling my foot out on there and messing
around with my toes and I'm listening to
everybody and still paying attention
what the hell is going on uh but I'm
always thinking you know how do I I
never really do one thing at once it's
always like multiple things going on and
I understand it like people sometimes
are like oh you can't be effective that
way but like when I run I'm either
listening to music which is helping me
grow and expand maybe like in my heart
in my mind uh and when I'm uh you know
sometimes on a run sometimes I'm
listening to a podcast or or a book and
maybe that is helping me to grow and
expand so I think with all these big
choices I think it's important all these
different choices you have I think it's
important to really fill your plate up
with stuff that's valuable and I guess
that gets to be the hard thing because
what is valuable to you our value
assignment our in our society is uh
sometimes misguided and miss it it
misarranged in a lot of ways there's we
have we have a tendency to really want
to listen to a doctor we have a tendency
to really want to listen to somebody
that's been doing something for a long
time but none of those things make any
sense to listen to them for anything
the only thing that should matter is
someone's explanatory knowledge when
they explain something to you does it
hold up to some things that you may have
heard in the past or or is it kind of
ruffling against some of that is there
some friction there and if there's some
friction there you might want to try to
figure out how do you smooth that out or
how do you uh maybe start to research
some of that on your own so with all
these huge choices out there
what I think is a wonderful thing is to
think about some of the people that you
see on social media
and maybe start to I know people don't
love this idea but
maybe start to mimic them a little bit
maybe start to say you know what I
really love that that guy's in Fitness
and the guy guy wrote a book like those
are really cool things I don't know if
I'll man I'm not sure about myself I
I don't I'm not great on camera but you
know maybe you can start to figure out
about your own versions of that I was
just talking with Nick bear today uh
about he just used to be so shy he's
like I didn't want it he has a podcast
and now Nick is a legend in the fitness
industry
he still doesn't really like to talk
especially about himself and so some of
the videos that you see sometimes it's a
video of him doing something and there's
a voiceover put to it later and there's
a strategy behind that because that's
his Niche that's what he feels good with
that's what he feels comfortable with so
kind of I guess trying to divide out
like you know drinking with your friends
or uh the direction that you went when
you were younger owning like a nightclub
like some of these decisions like they
might not they might match up with the
way you feel at the time or what you're
doing at the time but they also may not
match up with your goals because if you
are trying to be like a pro bodybuilder
and like run a nightclub or something
like that that would be difficult a very
diff yeah you put yourself in a
compromise position going back to the
reframing thing there's a quote from
Marcus Aurelius that I'm sure that
you're familiar with that says the whole
universe is change and life itself is
but what you deem it either gratefully
better than or bitterly worse than
something else that you alone choose but
I mean the whole universe is change and
life itself is but what you deem it so
that is talking about
what we are angry about for the most
part is not the thing it's the story
that we tell ourselves about the thing
and it is the perpetuation of the anger
by continuing to think about it Sam
Harris says this little experiment where
he says get angry about something and
then try to remain angry without
thinking about the anger it's impossible
it dissipates within two minutes that
you become the architect of your own
misery right you perpetuate these
problems yourself you're the person that
is coming in yeah maybe someone came in
and rang the bell but it's you that
continues to pick the hammer up and ding
ding ding over and over again
when it comes to situations that you are
triggered by
that ring the bell
what are practices that you go through
in order to reframe in a more effective
manner
I love this topic because I think so
much stuff has to do with like stress
mitigation
you know again using like uh grappling
as an example
if I learn something like a sprawl which
is to defend somebody taking me down if
I just learn that uh maybe for five
sessions and I get to try it out with
some different body types and different
people
the mitigation of somebody confronting
me wanting to uh take me on in some way
changes drastically the the stress of it
is like I don't know what the [ __ ] this
guy's problem is or what's going on here
but I'm pretty sure I'm going to be able
to uh handle myself at least okay so
it's directly proportional to your
capability or your competence of being
able to deal with it so I think so many
things are a skill set and these skill
sets that we acquire
can be ways to really dampen and
mitigate the stresses in our lives and I
think we have a tendency to day in and
day out just kind of sweep some stuff
under the rug sweep some stuff to the
side that we know that we should work on
and that we could work on but we think
of every possible thing uh that we that
we can to not do the thing we keep
putting it off we keep putting it off
you'll find yourself distracting
yourself with stuff that you don't
normally do like you might all of a
sudden start kind of cleaning out your
closet or something like that at home
it's like it's not a practice that you
normally do but you're doing it because
you know you're supposed to run five
miles for the day and and you you went
to grab your shoes and you're like this
closet's a mess and next thing and
you're just like you're you're wasting
all this time so that later on you can
kind of make the rational decision of
like I don't have the time to do that
for today and so for me to try to uh
mitigate or defend or or any of those
things it's like how can I learn or how
can I do what can I do what is something
I can go and do
so if something lands on me awkwardly
for the day and I I didn't particularly
like the way someone talked to me or
something stressful uh popped up I mean
the first thing is I don't have to
interpret it as being stressful I do not
have to interpret it as being negative
but sometimes that [ __ ] happens right
so if I did choose to put it in a
negative category then I would think
there's stuff that I need to do today
that it has always been in my best
interest it's what makes me and so you
can make up I Love This this term make
up your mind make up your mind to go and
do something else so for me it would be
like run or lift but it wouldn't
necessarily be direct it wouldn't be
like you know you and I are talking and
then all of a sudden we got this heated
discussion and I got stressed out or
something like that over so maybe
something you said insulted me or made
me sad maybe something you said I can be
a sensitive guy
maybe something you said made me sad and
I'm like man that really hurt man [ __ ] I
don't know how to explain that to him
that that hurt it's a little weird we
don't know each other that well I don't
even want to [ __ ] tell them so yeah
I'm just gonna go but I it wouldn't like
I wouldn't I guess what I'm trying to
say is I wouldn't necessarily like
you know uh go and run immediately after
that it's just like some part of the day
I'm going to run a lift and start to
contemplate that discussion a little bit
more so it seems like time creating a
buffer is a big part of this and that
goes back to not reacting immediately
time is a huge component but again I
also think
I have a saying of of do more be more
and sometimes people take that a little
bit they take that a little bit extreme
I know everyone's got like their morning
routines and they got these [ __ ]
rituals and [ __ ] and then they're trying
to optimize everything and I that's cool
like if that sets you forth in the down
the right path for you and uh it's been
a success for you that's really cool I
don't really I don't really operate that
way because I just have so much stuff
that I want to do in a given day
um that I'm gonna get to them so it
doesn't really have to be routine
um you can almost view it as a challenge
to sometimes be anti-routine so like can
you can you uh you can say to yourself
like am I so much of a [ __ ] that I have
to have my specific routine I have to
have like my raw milk in the morning and
I have to have this very specific thing
going on each and every day otherwise
I'm too thrown off and uh I get out of
balance I get out of equanimity
so do more be More's concept of
motion is the lotion movement is the key
movement is your motivation
motivation
is outstanding it can be a great thing
uh it can be a really strong
driver there's many different versions
of motivation that people can uh people
can get from all different kinds of
other people and other things
um
but I think the act of actually going
and doing something it could be anything
could be like gardening you could be
um hiking like for me it's just it's
pretty much just walking running lifting
but I have found that movement is the
most therapeutic thing that there is and
I think
and I've heard other people say stuff
like this I mean if you were if you were
to think of all the things put together
a compilation of all the things that
exercise resistance training all the
things that those things do that would
be probably like a four hour
pharmaceutical commercial listing off
all the positive things that it does and
maybe at the end it would say uh please
check with your doctor because this uh
this particular exercise could be very
addicting you know something like that I
might drop off at the end with like a
little negative caveat or you can overdo
it you can't hurt yourself something
like that but the benefits are
absolutely insane and I think it helps
when you make up your mind to safeguard
yourself from the outside world of all
the different distractions when you I I
kind of refer to it as fat proofing
because
when you have a child you baby proof
your home so your child doesn't get hurt
you put a block uh you know on the
stairs so they can't fall down the
stairs and you put things in the
electrical sockets and stuff like that
and I think you have to Fat proof your
life because the the world outside is
chaotic it's like a giant [ __ ] zoo
out there with all the different
uh types of convenient foods that are
bad for us however we're also in an
amazing time where if you're in the
United States especially I don't know
about all the other countries but
if you're in the United States and
you're in a especially if you're in a
prominent City you have so much access
to healthy good
food that is ridiculous probably almost
the same as you have to bad food yep
yeah so talking about the fragility of
routines this is literally the
newsletter that I sent out two days ago
for a long time when I first started
modern wisdom I was focused on
productivity and optimizing My Life
Strategies tools apps books and biases
that would improve daily efficiency my
presumption was that pretty much
everything would be fixed if I got more
focused and applied more effective
effort upon reflection I say there's an
important period to go through I think
everybody needs to spend a year or two
obsessing over deep work and
productivity kind of like how you need
to learn what Progressive overloading
good macros are for making strength
gains these are the physics of a
productive and efficient life but it's
an incomplete it's incomplete for a
number of reasons one of which I want to
focus on today having hardcore routines
makes you fragile and this is an Alex
homozy quote everyone can agree that
they feel better if they sleep well but
the issue is if you create the story
that you must sleep well in order to
perform if you make it a requirement to
function then that is is where you get
more negative ramifications from the
belief that you must have it it makes
you fragile you need to view all of your
optimal approach users preferences I
prefer to sleep more but if I don't I'm
still going to show up because winners
win and that's do more be more I think
that is look what's the actual outcome
goal that I'm aiming for here is my
outcome goal to have a fancy
productivity system that makes me feel
good about the process that I went
through in order to get to something or
am I just getting the work done by any
means necessary now this is not a
beginner's approach because you need to
understand the physics of what you're
trying to do you need to understand the
base it's all well and good you saying
do you know what it is I can do a little
bit of lifting a little bit of running
maybe I'll like roll within seamer and
get choked out a couple of times and do
BJJ but all of that works because it's
you've transcended individual uh domains
of training right you've transcended an
individual different type of programming
you can't do that in the beginning but I
think that holding on to this sort of
very rigid everything's about
productivity have to be as effective as
possible and I need to make sure that my
my Pomodoro time is perfect and the
morning routine that takes 90 minutes
and whatever whatever it's like okay
well what if you could get the same
amount of work done but with less of
that input maybe you've created some
habits that allow you to take less of a
dose of that maybe instead of doing
three hour strength sessions in the gym
which I imagine West Side would have
been you know these super long sessions
and like insane amounts of calories and
stuff okay well maybe my goals have
changed but maybe my Approach is better
maybe my Approach is more efficient or
effective now maybe some of the gains
that I've made in the past mentally or
physically are carrying over and giving
me this like afterburn effect across
years and years
so routines making you fragile yes 100
why do you believe that uh it's harder
to do if you're a beginner
or not advisable because I think that
it's there's too much complexity in that
that learning incrementally and
periodized okay I'm going to learn what
a strength routine looks like and you
need to spend you know six months to
three years
learning about how why cooking chicken
in different ways is to taste terrible
and how hard it is to get one gram per
pound of body weight in terms of protein
into your body and why you shouldn't try
and eat all of your food just before you
go to bed because it ruins your sleep
and what it feels like to do full body
every day and what it feels like to
train seven days and what it feels like
to train three days like you need to go
through all of those things and if
you're doing that whilst trying to do
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu whilst trying to do
a running program I don't think that you
condense and synthesize the learning
down into a pure enough form we have
limited Ram we have limited
um I just like where I would have
pushback is just against uh routine ever
pretty much
um because uh it's been my experience
that like the beginner phase can really
be like a lot of [ __ ] like like
you're talking about like like the
chicken and stuff like that like cooking
it like we get our knowledge from our
experience variances and or somebody
else's experiences it doesn't really
come from anywhere else so we we
experience these things or we've heard
previous experiences but
I'm a big fan of the term [ __ ] around
I think there's a lot of like [ __ ]
around that happens when you first start
lifting all the way to the point where
when you ask somebody when did you live
when did you start lifting they always
have two separate times well this is
when I began and this is when I started
doing it properly right right and it
would be nice to start out routine it
would be nice to start out with somebody
sat you down and explained a lot of it
and somebody's like this is a really
good program to stick to and you should
go three days a week and and all that
and and that and to that extent I think
you would be 100 right that person would
have way better progress probably uh
than the other person but
I'm a big fan of sticking with things
that you're interested in and sticking
the things that you like so my son and a
bunch of his friends have been training
in my gym for the last few years
and man it has been really difficult
I've had to bite my tongue because my
son just hangs out on the preacher curl
machine or at least he used to I'm like
I should have we should I should go sit
don't say anything go tell him to squat
no oh don't you know and it's just it's
killing me you know I'm like I'm like no
these are important like bro sessions
like I'm just so happy that he's in here
I'm so happy that he's finding some
interest relatively close to the things
I'm interested in I don't care that he's
just hanging out the preacher girl
hopefully ends up with freakishly large
uh biceps
uh so it's it's been it's been tough but
I've watched them him and his friends
all I mean literally grow like they're
they're all getting bigger and it's
really awesome and it's really fun to
see the Bro sessions going on there like
bench pressing I'm like you have a
training like it's every day that they
bench press but you remember they got
like yeah they got like one buddy who
like who who will actually follow like a
prescription or a program uh but most of
the time they're just you know hanging
out either benching or or doing curls uh
but again you know even with my running
the beginning stages of it was just like
let me just uh Shuffle I'm gonna run as
slow as I can uh just the Only Rule is
not to hurt yourself
and uh it's all been stuff that I that I
made up but again back to some of what
you were saying earlier I already have a
a large Foundation of physicality so I
know I yeah I I got a good understanding
whereas somebody else uh if they go and
they try too many things at one time
they're probably gonna get hurt mock
Bell ladies and gentlemen if people want
to check out the stuff that you do
online where should they go
you can go to markbaleslingshot.com and
that's where I have uh knee sleeves
elbow sleeves a slingshot product uh you
can also check out mind bullet my
favorite pre-workout you can go to
mindbullet.com and I'm at Mark's smelly
Bell on Instagram strength is never
weakness weakness never strength thank
you for having me appreciate it I
appreciate you thanks man thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]